ah son of a [ __ ] like check one two
Daniel do I hear talking to Peter Brant
down in here talking to Peter Brown
about Sony's new virtual reality headset
project Morpheus that you just played it
at GDC just down the road what are your
first impressions of this tech oh well I
was you know week ago I was like Sony's
never gonna do this they've done it and
you know what they've done a pretty good
job every other device that I've tried
so far that's trying to achieve the same
thing VR sony has mash and in some ways
bet you know improved upon some of the
things that I've seen in the past for
our first impression pretty good I'm not
pretty satisfied with it it's still very
early they're not even talking about
release date yet but already they've
made some pretty good progress okay you
give us a sort of an explanation of it
in terms of the oculus in terms of say
the technical specifications how it
feels when you put it on have it look
stuff like that so both of these devices
utilize stereoscopic vision where each
eye has its own screen and it's
essentially you know two independent
displays and and they render different
angles on the game so you get a 3d
effect and with a wide-angle field of
view what you get is that sense of
immersion which is what VR is going yeah
exactly
and you know both of the oculus and the
the project Morpheus are very similar to
one another in terms of performance
I saw the oculus for the first time two
years ago yeah and since then and it's
improved quite a bit yes it wasn't it
now it went was 720 version is they're
attending a version about as well yes so
at CES they debuted at Crystal Cove
which implemented a positional tracking
and 1080p one of those things sony has
the same thing right now
they're both roughly around the same
field of view angle but I need to great
90 degrees yeah
and but yeah no you know the performance
of each are very similar and I'd say you
know it's a long not a long time but
it's certainly a big gap between now and
the consumer release of both of these
bottles so I imagine the both improved
quite a bit how does it feel to actually
put on your head I know the oculus is
kind of like it's almost like putting on
a snowboarding mask or something's gonna
snap it on
is this more consumer-friendly because
it is a Sony product after all very much
interested in the mass market well so
I'm a I'm a good use case example
because I glasses so yeah little more
complicated and massive head as well
I just gigantic noggin it's a curse uh
not addressed well my brain is huge so
with the oculus you know I basically buy
stick it it like this and I pull the
strap over it's very simple Sony's is a
it's more of it's something that you
would place on top of your head okay
considering I have glasses I still have
to do a bit of that preparation where I
kind of dip my eyes in first once it's
on your head it's not as comfortable the
current iteration of the oculus the dev
kit number two which they just announced
this morning yeah I tried that out
yesterday and we put that on you don't
see anything outside of the you know the
little mask with Sony's headset I saw I
could see like a gap so they had to
tighten it so it was pretty tight on my
head in order to completely block out
the rest of the world around you um so
sorting is not as comfortable but what
it does have is a better focal point so
when you first put it on typically you
have to adjust these headsets to find
the sweet spot yes to wear this it's for
like a 3d s when you adjust the 3d
slider so working with your distance and
you're you know you're gonna make sense
you can kind of see where it clicked
feels right it clicks the oculus
requires a little bit more manipulation
so knees clicked but the the pixel
persistence what happens when so
something that causes motion blur is the
fact that pixels when the rendering your
frame if if it's going frame the frame
and interpolating as in calculating the
difference between frames yeah you get
motion blur effect one thing oculus has
done is they turn pixels on and off very
fast and they don't stick around very
long
I don't know how Sony is handling that
yet we didn't get into those specifics
but there is slightly more motion blur
with Sony's headset that said everything
is still early in a prototype so there's
there's time for these guys to improve
on what you know what they're doing I
currently I'm the GDC show for the
project Morpheus they're showing off a
sort of a shark cage demo there's a
castle demo and then they've also got a
Valkyrie which of course is playable on
the oculus
Oh what are the future plans for this as
a piece of something can buy in a store
they gonna is it just for PlayStation is
this something we'll see on PC or they
giving any details as to what they're
going to do next they're not talking
anything outside of the PlayStation
vertical right now right they're
basically trying to integrate it into
that brand and that's one of the strong
suits that Sony has they can implement
this in the hardware that already exists
has a consumer base and it's worth
noting that every peripheral they
released for the PlayStation 4 is
designed to work with the camera which
then works with the headset so Sony's in
a really good position that way and
they're designing this for Playstation
perimeter oculus is courting more of an
open source community environment
it's for PC primarily and really anyone
can develop for it
I even has a USB port people can design
their own peripherals and add it onto
the Yaqui where's the USB port well for
the oculus it's right on top ok Sony
does not have that USB port that's not
to say they won't support it in the
future I mean it's still very early you
know I can't stress that enough because
it's that no one's a winner yet both of
these guys are very close to one another
and perhaps they need one each other to
actually make this something that the
mass-market bites into it isn't just
something this game enthusiasts and tech
nerds are really interested in as well
it's well so that's the biggest
challenge is sort of breaking VR out of
that little bubble yeah because you know
in the past VR wasn't that great and a
lot of people still carry that stigma
where it's like ah they are maybe but
you know having used different
iterations of the oculus and watching it
evolve it's evolved very quickly and
certain experiences like eat Valkyrie
which is designed for VR from the start
is so different from porting a current
game to VR so I think once Sony can do
that then that's going to be a really
strong selling point when they have
those experiences that you can only get
with the project Morpheus or the oculus
but that yes they are kind of working
hand-in-hand to define the best
practices for dude no price point no
release date for this yet whatsoever
yeah all right well we look forward to
hearing more about if your brand's liked
you very much for talking to us about
project Morpheus and for more
information on dot I'm continuing
coverage of GDC right here in San
Francisco stay tuned to Gamescom
you